my family comes from russia they're
russian jews oh
russian ant jews is more like it one of
the biggest anti-semites i've ever made
russian away from japan well
i had a bar mitzvah norm yeah you didn't
yeah wait are you jewish yes
no no i'm kidding i love her i love the
jewish people
the lady i saw you with last night
that's rude bit of a hippo i read about
a hippo swallowing a man
and i thought of you no you remember
you remember ruth 21 years old he was in
a mcdonald's going you want lids on
these
everybody's different but it's worth in
that
now here can you pick it up out of here
yeah sure i'll pick it up for you here
no but while you're down there
walked off the bus it was just
it was just completely like this [ __ ]
heat barrier do you think you could do
that no try it though for the folks
you see vegas there's the saharan
okay are you jewish yeah okay then
you'll get it oh okay
okay half jewish no i'm full full jewish
full jewish all right then
but you're young so you might not get it
maybe okay so here's the joke holocaust
denier
awesome
we first met i met you
underneath the queensboro bridge
you at the time were jerking off punks
for 15
a man
my whole family's watching man my
grandmother
your family doesn't know that when you
were a young man you used to jerk off
punks for 15 dollars a man
the latest intermediate telling a joke
the uh the latest archie comic shows gay
character kevin kissing his boyfriend
devin another barrier will be broken
next month when in a dream sequence
jughead will be show fisting betty
crocker
god damn you're illiterate it's a
chauffeur
tell me your favorite episode of jsm uh
it was probably the episode where um
i love the one where david cross was uh
donnie
uh probably the one with the birds is
that when you won the bird cage
yeah yeah yeah oh we date a girl and she
puts this in a birdcage what was your
third favorite joke
okay okay you watch two
[Laughter]
earlier this week aaron jackson of
topeka kansas painted his house the
colors of the
gay pride rainbow flag in direct protest
of the westboro baptist church
when that didn't seem to work jackson
[ __ ] three of his best buds on his
front lawn
homophobic yeah well i know i think it
shows
earlier it was racist and now he's not
affordable i think it shows solidarity
all right this next one uh what are you
afraid of
next one here it says uh chipotle has
canceled its planned sponsorship
of the utah boy scout event due to the
bsa's ban on gay leaders and scouts
ironic how an all-male anti-gay
organization would want to put hot thick
loads of beef and sauerkraut okay okay
okay we get the idea you hate gay guys
we'll just do the last one
jesus christ
sounds like it's a test like if you
laugh then
yeah you're an [ __ ] or something like
that right exactly if you laugh at him
yeah that joke at that particular joke
like a test your testimony it's always a
test with this [ __ ]
this is what i have to work with you
know yeah
would you like to ask them a question um
not not right no right now not at the
moment
you want me to come back in a couple
weeks
gay people are just like me and you i
know how many times i have to tell you
that well
you can you tell me that all day how i'm
just like all the the
you know gay people okay people are the
same as everybody no you mean
you always tell me specifically how i'm
you're just maybe you're just
i think you're just calling me gay it's
one of the it's not an insult
no no no i didn't mean it why would
being gay be an insult yeah
i love gay people yeah i know
i think that's the end of the show
what's up how'd it go i just wanted to
uh
i just wanted to compliment you
yes you have a very nice tie
i like your shirt
uh michelle obama has booked a cameo on
the a b show
abc show nash start again sorry kids
today
i mean you can't you can't spell abc
wow what are you doing
on judge judy's the guest i had a i had
an idea oh you had an
idea what's this it's my nightstand
what's this
oh that's that's my real pistol and what
did i tell you about having ideas
they're good no i didn't tell you that i
have an idea
my idea is to pistol with you
did i get dressed you son of a [ __ ] we
have a show to do
he's a half a jew and a half a a
self-hating jew that's called
anti-semite
yeah he's a half a a proud jew and half
a
virulent anti-semites disagree
he's conflicted okay get ready to laugh
why is it so different to find
pornography about people in stable
monogamous relationships why is it so
what
different different difficulty
start all over and the joke still works
oh my god yeah he's an animal husbandry
for a while
really oh yeah i've had a you know
checkered past
well now there's nothing wrong with
being an animal husbandry unless it's a
euphemism
oh it's a youth okay then i don't want
to i don't want anything fair enough
no that's fine what was your joke
uh you had one joke no he was so
ridiculous
it was stupid what was that oh god man
it was something like uh
don't don't take a a shot from a girl at
a bar because it always it looks ridic
it's never good it's i i think the punch
line was is this a is this a
care bear [ __ ] shot or something it was
it was really ridiculous i i don't
remember it it was so long ago but that
was the gist of it and that's why i
don't do stand-up anymore
he can't even tell his own joke i mean
i'm not a good
you know anything yeah clearly
we'll be back with the ever funny adam
egan
[Music]
i'm going to remove my hat billy yeah
god no wonder no you keep your hat on
yeah that's fine that sounds good
actually
i think of comedians because you have
comic actors
and then you have writers and then you
have stand-up comedians the standard
comedians
are writers and what's that he's the
manager of the comedy store
[Laughter]
yeah you swallow that you [ __ ] you
drink that down you don't [ __ ] spit
that out yeah you like it you [ __ ]
drink it [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah but that amiga this is a true story
and he's straight
straight as an arrow but for money he's
not even looking at you in new york city
allowed to tell
oh should i tell this story yes in new
york city
he used to jerk off punks under the
queensborough bridge 15
a man
you know where this guy started he used
hip-hop he used to work under the
the queen
no queensborough bridge and he uh he
jerk off punks for 15
minutes that's when i first met him
but he's a good guy i can suck that
venom
yeah you [ __ ] suck that [ __ ] venom
yeah you want to spit it out you got a
[ __ ] mouth
[ __ ] shooting all your faces [ __ ]
good you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh thank you i can't get any of that in
my mouth
yeah no problem man we'll be back with
simon helper you [ __ ] sit down